[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
endgame principles video
i'm really looking forward to this video
because the topic today is a very
important one we will be talking about
pawn breakthroughs and
pawn breakthroughs are an integral part
of your overall endgame arsenal because
they apply
uh of course not only two pawn end games
but
as with many concepts discussing them
through the prism of pawn end games is
in my opinion the best and most
effective way to
to master them i'm especially excited a
little bit nervous because i kind of
have a gripe about how pawn end games
are taught in in chess literature and i
really wanted to get this video right
and so i took a pretty long time
preparing it i'm excited to share my
findings with you
now as is our tradition let's start with
a definition and this part is actually
more important than you might realize so
don't zone out
because the definition actually includes
a little clause that i haven't seen in
too many other definitions the way that
i choose to define pawn breakthroughs
is a temporary or permanent sacrifice
that creates a passed pawn or favorably
alters the pawn structure so
the important bits there are the fact
that it's a sacrifice
and that it does one of two things most
breakthroughs are aimed at creating a
past pawn not necessarily in one move as
we'll discuss but that's the ultimate
aim but not all pawn breakthroughs when
done properly create past pawns and
there's an entire category of pawn
breakthroughs which we will discuss that
aim to restructure uh the pawn formation
in a way that benefits your side that
benefits your king
so with the definition out of the way
let's get to the meat and let me switch
scenes
and here we go now the way that i've
chosen
to structure this video is as follows we
are going to go through 10 of the most
common
types of pawn breakthroughs in
abstraction as you'll see and i haven't
done any scientific research or
mathematical calculations this just
comes from my experience i've chosen the
10 that i've seen most commonly in chess
practice so we're going to discuss what
those are all about and then we're going
to move on to the practicum we're going
to take a look at six or seven examples
that feature these pawn breakers and you
will get a chance to practice
uh identifying
these pawn structures and putting these
breakthroughs into practice obviously
the examples are going to be a little
bit more involved and and convoluted uh
because i always try to give you sort of
the practical most practical application
and uh
the purpose of this video the main
purpose of this video is to help you
master typical uh
breakthrough scenarios structures and
substructures that allow breakthroughs
to happen uh but also
more generally
to help develop your sense of when a
pawn breakthrough might happen right so
i'm not pretending that these 10 typical
scenarios encapsulate all of the pawn
breakthroughs that will happen in your
games right hopefully it'll encapsulate
most of them but hopefully i will also
give you the machinery necessary to
quickly and effectively identify
opportunities to uh create pass bonds
via breakthroughs and the most fun part
of this video was the naming process i
had to name all of these breakthroughs
these typical breakthroughs to give you
uh hopefully a better memory marker i
don't think i'm going to be applying for
any creative jobs anytime soon so don't
judge too harshly
but that part was really really fun so
let's jump in and let's discuss the 10
most common types upon breakthroughs
okay so before we start with the first
position that's in front of you which is
the sort of most typical type of pawn
breakthrough i called it easy
spelled in the twitch way because it's
sort of the most obvious the most basic
type of pawn breakthrough which is of
course as you can guess the move g5
which clears the pawn out of f6 that's
the sacrifice and that's the past pawn
the pa the pawn
uh reaches promotion unobstructed
and the way that you can think about
this breakthrough is you're doing
exactly the same thing as if you would
have had a pawn not on f5 but on f4
right the concept is exactly the same
you're clearing the way for this pawn to
go forward this is the easy breakthrough
the most typical type of breakthrough
but
we're quickly going to reach
uh the breakthrough which i think is
most commonly taught when people talk
about pawn breakthroughs and generally
they just show that breakthrough and
then stop there except that type of
breakthrough is in my opinion one of the
the less common we'll get to it in a
couple of moments but first let's
continue with the bathtub formation
this is a type of pawn structure which
arises very frequently out of a
particular range of openings in
particular the karo khan those of you
who play the karaoke on with either side
you might recognize
this formation from a lot of your games
and it kind of looks like a bathtub i
didn't invent that full disclosure this
one
is pretty well known and uh once again
i'm showing these breakthroughs in
abstraction so these positions in
particular uh i just put the kings on a1
and a8 so i could make moves uh they're
not necessarily all winning for white uh
but i'm just trying to show the
breakthrough in action so
the deceptive thing about the battle
formation and about a lot of these
breakthroughs is that they they stem out
of relatively symmetrical pawn
structures and you might think well
because the pawn structure is totally
symmetrical uh
you cannot create a passport and that is
a complete illusion that's just not how
chess works and you shouldn't think
about it that way and if you look at
this position very carefully we'll see
that there is not one but actually two
different ways that white can forcibly
create a pass pawn the first and uh the
most typical is to play the move f5
now if black trades then it's all easy
you don't need a breakthrough you just
play e6 and you create a passer but the
question is what do you do if white
black doesn't trade if black just waits
and this is the important bit you shove
this pawn all the way through to f6
now black most of the time has to trade
because if black pushes then you either
take on pissant or you take simply take
g6 and the f1 of course
inevitably promotes so once black takes
on f6 hopefully you see where this is
going you take back and now you've set
the stage for the actual breakthrough
now the easy breakthrough with g5
forcing the pawn out of h6 and uh you
create a corner passer and a lot of
these breakthroughs actually result in
you having a corner past pawn which if
you've watched the previous video you
know is a huge asset outside passers are
among the most dangerous so this is the
bathtub formation
next we have the pawn square and this is
one of my favorites this is one that is
most
commonly blundered by chess players of
all levels as we'll see and the pawn
square arises in the following scenario
so let's assume that it's black to play
in this position
and black is thinking and says well i
want to create a pass pawn on my own so
what i'm going to do is play the move g6
and then i'm either going to take h5 and
create a past f pawn or after the trade
i'm going to go h5 looks totally
watertight right
rongo the pawn square is created when
you play g5
this is the square and this is a deadly
idea because it forces the h6 pawn off
of the board or off of the h file and
inevitably creates a pass pawn the funny
thing is that it allows black to create
a past one as well but most of the time
your passpond is going to be so much
further advanced than blacks in fact in
this concrete position white actually
wins with the move g5 so the pawn square
kind of comes out of nowhere it's
incredibly important to identify
opportunities to create a pass pawn this
way and it can allow you to swindle a
lot of lost positions as we'll see in
the practice part
next we have what i call the head
chopper uh i named it this way because
well you essentially chop the head off
of i'm sorry it's very vulgar you chop
the head off of black's structure but
hey you'll remember it better and then
you create a pass pawn and again there
are two ways to do it uh symmetrical but
uh the the basic idea is that you go f5
or you can go h5 but this is the way to
create an outside passer if black
ignores then you push if black takes
then uh you play h5 and then you play g6
and you create a past pawn or go h5 you
do the same thing on the other side
of uh of the board
so notice that in this case it's not the
breakthrough itself that creates the
past pawn so we can amend our definition
to say that a breakthrough is a
sacrifice that creates or aids in the
creation of a passport right you
sacrifice in order to create this
majority and then you use this majority
uh to
uh to to create a passpond so this is
the famous head chopper next we have
another one of my favorites i called it
i couldn't decide a name for this one
for the longest time i called it east
gust best ghost because essentially you
promote on the right side of the board
very uh sophisticated i know and it
occurs very specifically what i want you
to see here is black's pawn structure in
this position and of course all these
breakthroughs can be uh
sort of put
done with colors reversed it's just that
i'm doing this for convenience sake
right we're examining them all from
white's point of view uh so the point
here is that you're actually going to
still create a past h-bond even though
it doesn't look like you can create a
pass pawn at all blacks pawns are kind
of deep freezing widespawns to use a
term from earlier in the video but uh
there is a simple breakthrough here and
then there's a more complicated one the
simple breakthrough and the less
frequent one is the move h5 you're
threatening h6 you're forcing black to
take and then you go f5 e6 but this
doesn't create an outside pastor and
frequently black's king
uh or white's king if you're breaking
the rule black can stop one of these
past pawns so the more conventional way
of doing this is to play f5
again if black doesn't do anything you
kind of know the drill you go e6 or you
can go f6 first and then e6 and if black
takes
uh
again you have another breakthrough that
you can make you can play g6 and create
a past e pawn this way but the standard
application here is to play h5 and then
h6 and create a past h-bond this
structure actually occurs very very
frequently and opportunities for this
kind of breakthrough are often missed
even by very strong players as we will
see
so east coast best coast okay we already
did this one that's the typical
breakthrough next we have
the undoubler
and uh the undoubler is actually not a
breakthrough that's done in order to
create a pass pawn and this is the
important bit because i just feel like
these types of breakthroughs are not
often talked about and they're often not
fully understood by players so listen
carefully uh you know you'll you'll want
to master this
okay so
essentially we have a position like this
and as you can understand from the title
of the from the name of this
breakthrough uh the way it's going to be
done is you're going to play f6 and
you're going to sacrifice the f-pawn and
un-double your pawn yeah your f pawn so
black essentially most of the time has
to take
and then you're going to get this type
of pawn structure and you might ask well
why the heck would we want to change the
structure in this way well imagine for a
second that our kings were not on a1 and
a8 let's bring the kings a little bit
closer together right
let's create a position
like i don't know like this right
what it's hard to make progress right
now because if you try to shoulder the
black king and try to squeeze it to the
right side of the board you're actually
going to lose the game right you're
going to lose all of your puns but what
you can do is play f6 in order to use
black's pawn as a shield not allowing
black's king to infiltrate and now
you're able to shoulder black's king off
of the board and win the f6 bond and win
the game this is a very important type
of breakthrough and it's very easy to
identify right when you have these types
of doubled pawns and your opponent has
one pawn that's stopping them you always
need to think about sacrificing one of
your double pawns in order to
alter the structure
in this way
next we have what i call the corner kick
this is a very similar type of
breakthrough to east coast best coast
because you sacrifice a set of pawns in
order to create a passer but what
distinguishes east coast best goes from
the corner kick breakthrough is then in
the corner kick breakthrough the
opposing side does not have double pawns
right that's just uh something i've done
for for convenience so you can keep
these separate in your mind and uh the
way you do this is you go f6 now
obviously you can just take on f6 and
create a passpond that way but if you're
trying to create an outside passer what
you do is you sack another pawn this is
the easy breakthrough and after h takes
g6 you play the move uh you play the
move h6 and
you have uh here a corner pass pawn so
the corner kick named after the pawn
that ultimately does the promoting right
boom boom
you could also guess call this a free
kick um but in any case black takes both
of your pawns and the h-bond promotes
and makes a queen
now uh one other breakthrough
that is relatively elementary i was
meaning to show this earlier but again i
it doesn't really matter
i just want to get through all of these
so you can kind of um keep them straight
in your mind and and
i didn't tell everybody but you know i
would be writing these down if i were
you just maybe uh taking some notes and
trying to associate them in your mind
you know trying to make sure that you're
internalizing them that's going to help
you in the practicum and this one is
a form of the easy breakthrough you
basically set up an easy breakthrough
but this is a very important one right
so you go h4
and then of course again you can go g5
and create a pass coupon but let's say
you want a uh corner pawn what you do is
you go h5 and you stop black's h6 pawn
freeze it in place and then you go g5
and this is often effective because the
move g5 allows black to play h5 and once
again you don't have a corner passer
this can be important if black's king is
in the vicinity and can catch the pawn
we'll see this in action in one of the
games so you play h5
then you play g5 uh forcing the pawn out
of the way and then you play h6 so what
you'll see is that a lot of these
essentially boil down to the easy
breakthrough but there's a preliminary
segment where you have to uh either sack
a pawn or change the pawn structure in
some way to allow a basic breakthrough
to happen and finally we have a square
clearer which is another type of
breakthrough that usually doesn't isn't
done to create a past pawn although it
also can and the abstract breakthrough
that i'm showing you does incidentally
create a passpond but that's not the
point of it
so we have a position like this right
where if it's white to move white may
seem to be in zugzwang and i'll talk
about that in a separate video but a
situation where every move harms your
position in some way right you have to
move your king back and then black's
king advances forward and the pawn on c6
and the king seem to form this sort of
impenetrable force field which don't
allow white to do anything but this the
the square clear
uh results after d5 check here so you
sacrifice the pawn what square are you
clearing you're clearing the square
formerly occupied by the pawn onto which
the king now steps you go king d4 and in
this specific position it's still a draw
because white isn't able to win this
resulting end game but again that's not
the point the point is that this
particular type of breakthrough often
puts the opposing side either in
zugzwang or
we'll see another scenario where if you
clear a particular square for your king
you're basically just able to win the
game straight away so we actually
examined two different breakthroughs
which aren't necessarily performed in
order to create a past pawn right the
square clear and then the pawn on
doubler so let me just make sure uh that
we have all these breakthroughs
internalized i'll go through them one
more time really really quickly just to
name them uh so you can write them down
in your notes
so we had of course the bathtub
formation we had the oh and one more i
forgot to uh i forgot to show this one
which is the dynamite uh breakthrough
and the ironic thing about this this is
my gripe with the way that pawn
breakthroughs are taught
i see this position in almost every
lecture every video on pawn
breakthroughs and this is generally all
that people show and this is a
very rare type of breakthrough but i
show this because it's it's so commonly
uh commonly shown and i think the reason
that people are so attracted is because
it's really pretty and it shows the
concept that a symmetrical pawn
structure does not mean that you can't
create a past pawn hopefully many of you
are familiar with it and the way it goes
is like this you have a three
facing a three
right here white strikes in the center
with the move g6 and
whichever way black takes white pushes
the adjacent pawn to create a passer so
if black takes with the h1 then you push
the pawn that's to the left of it you
play f6 forcing the g pawn out of the
way and then you play h6 if black takes
with the
left one then you push the right pawn
you push the uh pawn that's on the
opposing side which makes sense right i
mean the f6 doesn't make any sense
because black still has the h pawn so
you play h6 black has to take and then
you play f6 and you advance the spawn to
promotion
now to date i never had this particular
type of breakthrough in one of my games
uh and the wake it is often stopped
right is with the opposing side playing
a move like g6 and preventing the
breakthrough from happening but not f6
because here you can play h6 a very
common type of blunder dislodging the g
pawn and creating a far advanced passer
my brother who's 2100 he actually fell
for this many years ago and i remember
he called me and you know he was
obviously embarrassed because he knew
this breakthrough but forgot about it
but other than that i've really never
experienced it nonetheless it's uh it's
very famous and i wanted to show it for
for the sake of completeness
but as you can see there are all these
other types of breakthroughs which are
in my opinion far more common and far
more important to understand so we have
the bathtub formation we now have the
dynamite we have the pawn square
uh this is the head chopper then we had
the east coast besides this is a
particularly important one the easy
breakthrough is what we started with
that's where you just break through and
sacrifice upon we had the pawn on
doubler where you go uh f6 basically
and on double your pawns we had the
corner kick we had the square clear
and uh
i think and we had to stop and go so one
two three four
five six seven eight just making sure
i'm counting right nine
and ten excellent so i counted correctly
there we go and now we get to
the practicum and i see that only 17
minutes have passed so we're moving
right along we can now spend a good
quality time on applying these
breakthroughs okay
and of course feel free to watch this
segment several times and one thing that
you can also do if you had any recent
pawn end games you can now go through
them and see if you can identify already
any breakthroughs that may have been
missed or maybe you found them you can
now categorize them and i think that's
an instructive process overall now we
get to the fun part we get to the
application and for all of the games
that i'm about to show what i recommend
you do
as usual is you pause the video when i
first display the position and you take
your time you try to solve it you can
assume that the the side to move is the
side that we are facing in this case it
is
white to play and i've chosen
deliberately examples that are not very
famous examples often from games between
you know 18 1900s players good players
uh but that is a level at which pawn
breakthroughs are very frequently
overlooked now this is a pretty direct
application of the bathtub formation
what you will see if you become an
expert in pawn breakthroughs is that you
will automatically learn to filter out
the stimuli that are not important to
filter out the rest of the pawn
structure right you rarely have only the
pawns that are responsible for the
breakthrough and what you need to do is
you need to pick out the sort of
uh the hazelnut at the center of the
ferrero rocher candy i have no idea
where that analogy came from i think my
english teacher actually made that
analogy about something uh and in this
case of course you should identify the
bathtub
formation and white wins the game in
exactly the way that we discuss black's
king is far away and it's blocked in by
its own pawns white starts with the move
f5
uh and the game is essentially over
black tries to ignore it plays b5 and
white plays f6 shoving this pawn down
the board and after the trade
ereza tried to get uh his king as close
as possible white has no time to waste
king e5 is a threat and the sort of
automatic king d4 would actually lose
the game uh to the move e5 check
followed by king e6 so you don't you
don't want to waste time you want to go
g5 and uh there's a little cool part
about this which is that okay black
takes hg then white goes h6 there's not
much to calculate in this pawn race uh
it's not a very fair one but black did
something kind of clever he went king e5
in this position and after gh6 he went
king f6 and it actually looks like
black's king has successfully dealt with
the puns which is a common
outcome of pawn breakthroughs you
shouldn't expect that you promote every
single time but
if you look at this carefully you will
see that black is in zugsbong
king move allows the pawns to promote so
all that white has to do is just wait it
out right you gotta just wait out the
rest of black's pawn moves and white
played king d4 black resigned
black's only pawn move is b4 you know a4
is similar you just take it and go a3
black has one more pawn move you take d5
and the game is over black has nothing
better than to give away the e pawn and
then finally he's going to have to move
his king so that's a a very important
type of position where one of your past
pawns is blocking both pass bonds are in
a very elegant fashion blocking the king
from stopping them that's why doubled
pawns are so underrated in chess and
shouldn't be scoffed at the one other
thing that i'll point out after f5 more
resilient would have been to take on f5
because here you obviously don't want to
rush with e6 uh because black tastes and
stops the pawn
but this is where you know knowledge
that you acquire in all of the videos
kind of stacks on top of each other
hopefully the previous videos should
have helped you
figure out a good way to win this
position but the awesome part is after
b5 the most effective win is to use
another breakthrough the square clearer
and it is via a square clear that white
puts black in zugsman so once again
pause the video see if you can find a
square clear to win the game not the
only win but uh the most effective one
and i'll take a sip of water in the
meantime
so the win is yielded with the move b4
check a takes before king b3 a square
clear and a breakthrough that doesn't uh
involve creating another pass pawn this
puts black and zuke's one black can't
push any of his pawns black has no
choice but to move his king back and
then after king takes before king b6 you
use another concept that you acquired
the notion of creating an outside pass
pawn the classical plan so you create a
decoy pass pawn you use this decoy pass
spawn to draw the king away then you
take b5 and the rest is easy you just
push this a pawn uh you win the d-pawn
and the game is the game is over king d7
king c5 and black has to choose between
giving away this pawn then you get
trousers or stopping this pawn and
allowing the a pawn
to promote so a bathtub formation here
resulting in a past pawn and there could
have been a space clear if black had
defended more resiliently
okay on to the next one
uh this is another game that's not
particularly famous two players in the
2000 rating range and
this one is uh really really tragic i'm
sure uh calderon zulaga has not
forgotten this game because white is
winning in the initial position the way
that white wins this is incredibly
instructive in its own right which is
why i chose this position particularly
like it could have given you a million
examples of this breakthrough first
let's take a look at what actually
happened so white
uh plays the unassuming move a3 looks
like a pretty normal move which was
pushing upon black responds by closing
the pawn structure with a4
okay now what white should have done
here is gone
before and pushed this pawn through but
instead calderon goes king e3 and i
think his logic is that he thinks that
black is in zugzwang right and he thinks
okay black has to take b3 and then i'm
gonna create an outside passer and i'm
going to win
but
those with a keen eye for breakthroughs
will recognize the error of his ways and
they will recognize why black played a4
the reason black played a4 is to
establish a pawn square and after b4
white is losing and the hilarious thing
is that in playing king e3 white
actually went away from the queen side
which means that this a pawn is now
going to be unstoppable and after a
takes b3 a3 a takes before a3 black made
a new queen white made a couple a couple
more moves but resigned very quickly
because this pawn is unstoppable this is
a serious player who missed a pawn
square and even a lot of grandmasters
have overlooked this concept as well now
let's get back to the starting position
and talk about what white should have
done
now what you will notice if you've sort
of mastered the previous videos that the
h4 pawn is very annoying it's deep
freezing two of white's pawns
but that doesn't mean you can't
circumvent the deep freeze and you can
circumvent the d freeze by bringing your
king to f2 right a breakthrough with g3
would be foolish because it would give
black a very far advanced passer but you
can get your king to f2 and then push g3
to
uh get out of the deepers and create an
outside password and the best way to do
this is to start with the move c3 the
point is to stop black's king from
advancing to d4 that's like when they
would bury vampires right you'd put
spikes on the grave right you're not
allowing that king to rise up from the
dead black's king has nothing better to
do than to just move back and forth and
the problem is that black ever goes
before you just go c4 getting a connect
uh protected pass pawn and winning the
game immediately so black has nothing
better to do than to just sit around and
wait now you go king f2
now here's the really cool part if black
continues to wait then it's obvious you
go g3 and hopefully you can see that
trousers are inevitable you're going to
push the h pawn in at the right moment
you're also going to push the c pawn and
create a second passer black can only
create one passer that is easily
restrained by white's king
okay so uh the question of course is
well what happens if black doesn't
cooperate and black plays f4 but f4
creates a gaping hole on e4 that's very
important it also prevents black
hamstrings black uh from creating a pass
pawn of his own so now you go back with
your king you go king e2 if black waits
then you go king d3 and hopefully you
know the drill you create a passer again
using it as a decoy then you go king e4
and you mop up all of flex uh you know
crippled king side pawns which can now
no longer defend themselves
black can try the move e4 here but now
you trade and you do exactly the same
thing c4 is not as effective because
black takes and goes king d4 instead you
want to go a4 a very important concept
because a lot of people think oh if i'm
creating a pass spawn i want it to be as
far advanced as possible but as we
discussed in
the video upon races that's not always
true uh sometimes you want the pawn to
be as far away from the enemy king right
because you're using this pawn as a
decoy you're not trying to promote it
and to use it as a decoy you want the
distance between that pawn and the enemy
king to be as high as possible so the
best move is to play a4 that pawn stays
on c3 black has to waste additional time
going king d5 and black is just in zoo
song now you go king d3 and you can
simply promote uh you can simply promote
this pawn actually the move king f3 also
wins
um it also wins you can take f4 and then
go g4 and the pawn race is uh wait a
minute no the penry's actually not
easily winning because by applying rule
one of pawn races not taking unnecessary
pawns black ghost king b3 and you get a
queen end game or white's still winning
uh so in fact uh white should play king
d3 and then c4 that's uh that's the
bottom line here
and uh upon square never too late to
save the game
next we have a an example from
grandmaster practice two grandmasters
two british grandmasters facing off
against each other
and in this rook end game white played
the
the unassuming move king d2
black thought about it and said okay
i've got a pawn majority on the queen
set and like the good and game master
that i am i know that i can win by
forcing a rook trade then using my pawn
majority to create a decoy and winning
white's king side pawns what could be
wrong without logic watson played rook
c4
pause the video
and see
if you can figure out whether there was
a fly in the ointment
okay well if i'm asking the question uh
hopefully you were able to figure out
that there in fact is and white in fact
should trade rooks
and uh those of you with a keen tactical
i will recognize the corner kick
formation right it's a slightly
different type of pawn structure but the
the bottom line is exactly the same you
play the move f5
this is what watson had overlooked he
took on a five
here's another breakthrough it's
incredibly important not to go h5 first
again don't procrastinate and always
understand where your opponent's king is
and try to figure out
how urgently you need to act in this
case you need to act very urgently h5
and watson resigned after king d5 g6 the
funny thing is white doesn't even need
to
play the move h6 white can just take on
g6 and then promote straight away and
a very strong grandmaster simply
overlooked this now one other important
line is king d5 which would have
actually been more resilient what does
white do here well here we have another
breakthrough which i showed in the sort
of theoretical segment e6 f takes c6 and
now what do you do now a very very
important moment pause the video see if
you can figure it out this is just as
crucial as the initial position
so here you should identify that you
have an easy breakthrough
that wins the game on the spot i think a
lot of people would be tempted to play
f6 but after king d6 the puns the king
stops the pawn and this is actually a
draw black threatens to create trousers
so white can deep freeze black's pawns
but in this position there is simply no
way to make progress and you can
convince yourself of this by setting
this up on a board and moving your
pieces around but this is actually a
draw but it's all a moot point because
if you allow yourself to consider other
options you'll see f takes g6 hg6 h5 and
i love this the fact that the e61 is
actually blocking black's king from
stopping white's pawns gh5 g6 and the
game is over
um
king e6 is impossible it's illegal and
this is one of the most elegant things
about pawn breakthroughs the fact that
they often leave your opponent's pawns
on squares where they're obstructing the
king that's not a coincidence that
happens pretty frequently and that's
something that you should factor in to
your thinking so
in this way levitt was able to swindle a
very bad rock end game had black simply
played rook h3 black has excellent
winning chances
watson never lived that down and retired
from chess after this game fun story not
just kidding he didn't retire from chess
but uh i'm sure he didn't forget this
one for a while and another one
that uh
will not be forgotten for a while is the
game between weinstein and michael rhode
who is now a very strong grandmaster and
a lawyer
but in this game tragedy struck for road
um he did not take the right road
okay that was that was low hanging fruit
i had to do it i greatly apologize i
understand that you might unsubscribe
you will be forgiven if you do so so
it's black to play here let's flip the
board
it's black to play in this position and
as with the previous example
you would be forgiven for thinking that
white is totally winning because white
has the stock plan right past pawn get
the gang over win black's pawns but
hopefully by now you've realized that
you can't think like that you have to
look at the actual pawn structure you
can't be fooled into thinking that just
because it doesn't look like you can't
create a passer means you can't create a
passer and if you've paid attention
during the theoretical segment you will
see that this is almost an exact
application of
east coast best coast
okay let's go back to east coast best
coast just a moment let me
find it no this is the this is the
corner cake so this is the very similar
one
this is east coast best coast and
essentially what we do is we ultimately
need to get rid what do we need to get
rid of well we need to get rid of one
pawn and then we need to get rid of the
other pawn so we in this case just push
f5 and then push h5 h6
back we go to the
uh road game
um
in this position okay let's flip the
board again black starts by playing f4
and that should be pretty obvious
although that's not what road played
we'll get to that in a moment
okay now if y doesn't trade
now it's a direct application you play
f3
and after g takes f3 you don't
automatically take f3 stealing a rule
from the pawn race chapter um don't take
unnecessary puns right and you can't
make any assumptions in pawn end games
about what needs to be done you don't
need to recapture stuff that wastes time
you just go h4 you've done the hard work
now you do the easy work of creating a
passer and again we have a scenario in
which white's pawns actually block the
king from stopping black's passer white
uh loses in that line so after f4 and i
think this is the reason why rode didn't
play this white plays g takes f4
you play g takes f4 notice some of you
might be tempted by g4 but here y can
defreeze the pawns by playing g3
so you actually do recapture here and
after king d4 it's easy to stop
calculating and say that's it i'm losing
all of my pawns
and yet now we take a page out of the
corner kick
and it turns out that we can get rid of
that g pawn not by playing f3
immediately because here i can sync the
entire battleship with g3 but by first
playing e3 forcing this pawn out of the
way creating a temporary pass pawn
forcing this one out of the way and
after h4 yet another scenario in which
the pawns are blocking white's king from
preventing the h-bond from promoting
what an amazing breakthrough this would
have won wrote the game and instead what
did he do and i think he just lost hope
and rather than playing f4 he played h4
is this symmetrical is this the same
thing no because after ghgh the
opportunity train has left the station
white goes king d4 and you can't go f4
anymore you lose e4
and you're just not in time to go f3 the
king takes the pawn
and so road had nothing better to do
than to go king e6 and now white wins
with the conventional method
trade king d6 a6 the game is over king
c6 king e5 and white took all the pawns
and i i really wonder if if
weinstein realized that black had this
during the game
it would be pretty crazy if they came
back to their hotel rooms and then rode
realized that uh computers didn't exist
of course the time this was the 1970s uh
maybe i'll actually send michael wrote a
message not to remind him of you know
of
painful memories but nonetheless uh this
would be this would be an interesting
thing to pull him on the move f4 again
you have the east coast west coast which
is tightly related to the corner kick
the bottom line is that you get rid of
both of these pawns and you create a
past h pawn you can see the other theme
uh by which pawns are actually
obstructing the king stopping it from
stopping the pawn ooh so this one i
should have rewinded to the start but
that's okay that's okay uh it's a bit of
a giveaway but that's fine this is a
very instructive one right another game
between two 21 hundreds
and uh let's start in this position
because i think it's instructive the way
that the the game unrolls and leads up
to the pawn breakthrough so in this
position black makes a very ingenious
move a very ingenious move goldberg
plays queen c4 and he basically says
okay i'm fine getting into a pawn end
game but i'm doing it on my terms
and white decided to trade which is a
mistake actually
why is it a mistake because goldberg
takes what the d pawn is so far this is
all correct and he correctly identified
a potential pass pawn that can be
created on the queen side so yet again
you might have a situation where black
creates a decoy passer on
the
uh queen side but you would also be
correct in identifying a bathtub
formation
okay
so you have a bathtub formation
and where is that what does that lead to
so can you play like f5 here right
well not really because first of all
white's already played g4 g5 right in
the bathtub formation we want to play f5
f6
and this is a sub-optimal way of
creating a password g6 is out of the
question it gives black a protected
outside passer and the king is way too
close for any pawn breakthroughs uh to
be to be effective let me just give you
a moment
charge my keyboard a little bit
okay
in the meantime start thinking about
what can be done instead
okay
okay
there we go
so uh basically after queen c4dc white
has nothing better to do than to
approach the king approach the center
with his king he goes king f3
and here black makes an incredibly
instructive mistake goldberg probably
quickly played king d7
totally reasonable right king e4 king c6
you get the game into the center that's
what you're taught
and yet this fails to a breakthrough
and what he should have done is played
a5 as quickly as possible creating a
pass pawn on the queen side we'll get to
that first let's figure out what the
heck is wrong with this move pause the
video see if you can figure out which
breakthrough applies here and there's a
bit of a red herring i deliberately
implanted the bats information in your
mind to make you not realize that there
is another breakthrough i'm evil like
that
but hopefully you were not fooled and
hopefully you can see that the
conditions are optimal for a square
clearer you go d5 check
and then you go king d4 and once again
black is not only in zugzwang but the
square clear in this case also benefits
the kingside pawn formation because now
you are ready to create a passer now
you're ready to exploit the bat up
formation by playing f5 you've gotten
rid of the e6 pawn and so you've
circumvented the drawback of the move g5
and black resigned here because after
hgf6 gf you play h6
and you win
the game the pawn promotes to a queen e
takes f6 by the way is actually really
really bad another great example of
where you shouldn't automatically
recapture puns it might seem like this
pawn race is laughably decided white
stops the pawn but trousers here comes
the other pawn with check and amazingly
black is better after h7 d2
uh king e2g2 black promotes at the same
time as white and black promotes with a
check by sacking one of the pawns and
promoting the other one a typical idea
black is better in the end game so you
have to go h6 here but black resigned
after f5 realizing that f6 is
unstoppable and black wasn't able to
create anything on the queen side so
instead of going king d7 black should
have played a5 now you might how would
that have helped after king e4 black
plays b4 and there's the rub a takes
before a takes b4 and if white tries to
do the same exact thing then black takes
on d5
and you might say well this is the same
thing but clearly it's not because
black's king is now a lot better
position black simply goes up to e6 and
there's nothing that white can do i
can't even move past d4 with this king
because of the possibility of an
unstoppable pass pawn being created so
uh just a really really instructive
right a5 creates the preconditions for a
passport it keeps the king as close to
the site of the breakthrough as possible
instead black kind of automatically
brought the king up to c6 allowing the
square clear which not only clears the
square for the king but also creates a
past pawn so as you can see some of
these breakthroughs are in a gray area
right you can have one type of
breakthrough but it could be done for a
different reason
uh this is the stop and go breakthrough
that we already talked about
um it's just that my examples were a
little out of order this is another
instructive game this is a pretty simple
one uh a game between a 2100 and a 1600
it is white to play
uh
what should white do in this position
pause the video try to figure it out
so hopefully you were able to see that a
stop and go scenario is on the card so
what you do here is you go h4 now here's
the interesting thing black could have
prevented the breakthrough by moving his
king to e6
and meeting h5
uh with the move f6
but here's what black did instead and
this is as instructive as the
breakthrough itself
black pushed the a pawn and this is a
very very common mistake at
all levels really and black is a very
capable player just sort of pushing
pawns without really realizing why is a
big no-no and there will be another
video specifically dedicated
specifically dedicated to waiting moves
which essentially says that you
shouldn't push pawns you shouldn't give
up waiting moves unless you need to
because you want to keep your waiting
moves in reserve they could be they
could be of tremendous importance in
causing zug's lungs so if we go back for
a second to the position after king e6
if white were to play h5 black actually
wins with the move king f6 now you might
say what are you talking about i have a
square clear and black is in zouzong
he's got to move his king
well no he doesn't because some genius
decided to leave uh
leave himself with a series of waiting
moves black plays a5 and it is actually
white who has to move the square clear
has been a disaster white has to move
the king back and he loses the game
because black is connected passers so
after king f6
black already wins and white should just
move the king back and this is a draw
this is a total standoff neither side
can do anything but because black played
a5
now white plays h5
and black is now actually in zug's one
by dao's played a4 but now it's time for
the square clear g5 check king g4 and
king takes g5 is coming and of course
uh the game is easily won because white
has the outside passer in the game black
did not take the pawn when king g7 but
white king f5
and the rest is very easy h6 check and
king f6 the classical plan and white
wins the pun so another combination of
two different breakthroughs identifying
the stop and go breakthrough but then
realizing that uh you have the square
clear but also instructed from the point
of view that it shows that you shouldn't
just push random pawns you should
usually try to keep your extra pawn
moves in reserve in case you get a
situation where you have a standoff
and both sides are exhausting their pawn
moves down to the last two examples
we're moving at a good pace here and
this is really one of my favorite ones
because it it really is such a direct
application of uh of a pawn breakthrough
that's just not often talked about now
it's white to play in this position this
comes from a blitz game that i played
against you yankee very strong
grandmaster a couple years ago and it's
white to move clearly i'm trying to win
i'm upon uh but but can white actually
make progress in this position so once
again pause the video see if you can
figure something out
so hopefully you were able to see that
white has the potential to trade queens
with queen f4 check and because white is
up upon you might say that it's well
it's easily winning but i didn't do this
and the reason i didn't do it is because
i figured that with my pawn structure as
hamstrung as it is i would not be able
to make progress and again this was a
blitz game i was really low on time
but if you listen carefully during the
theoretical segment you will see that
the preconditions are optimal for what
kind of breakthrough
a pawn
on doubler so before undoubling your
pawns it's worthwhile to bring your king
up to e4
you get exactly the kind of scenario we
talked about and now the only way to win
is to play f5 check
this is also a type of square clear but
the main purpose of it is to undouble
your pawns and create a scenario after
f3 waiting move zugzwan black has to
move the king to the side and whichever
way he goes white goes the other way a
classic scenario and white wins the game
white wins f5 and the rest is
uh an easy theoretical win and actually
after f4 you can take on f4 but even
more effective is to ignore that pawn
and shoulder black's king all the way
back to take h5 and then take f4 that's
even easier
so had i understood had i identified
the pawn structure here i would have
probably seen this in a couple of
seconds
but i didn't bother to think about it i
just looked at the fact that the pawns
were doubled and i thought well there's
no way to win
because i thought in this position you
just have to dilly dally with your king
there's no way to make progress and yet
there is you break through not to create
a pass pawn but in order to shoulder
black's king into oblivion
and finally we have a game of gary
kasparov i think it's always fitting to
end with a uh
with
because
with a kasparov game
and this is yet another example of a
square clear and the reason i've had a
lot of these examples because i think
it's so easy to forget about these types
of breakthroughs
and uh and just sort of forget that they
exist so in this position it's white to
play we have a similar question as in
the previous example should white trade
queens or not
what do you think kasparov chose
so
if you think that trading queens is bad
because
well because
it just seems like
why there's no way to make progress and
black is actually better due to his king
position i would forgive you right
that's a tempting assumption to make but
look very carefully at the pawns and see
if you can figure out
whether there might be a breakthrough
hopefully you were able to see that
white has in store the possibility of
pushing his pawn to d5 when the moment
is right king d3 king f4 and the square
clear with d5 after cd5 white's king
steps up to d4 takes d5 travels around
and takes black's pawns
now the amazing thing and again i'm
deliberately including these examples
where it's not just about the
breakthrough i'm trying to get you to
think about other concepts as well this
will be a nice way to preface our later
videos which just examine complex end
games black can actually still draw and
nikolic he lost his cool here he he lost
hope and he just went for the automatic
king f5 then he played king f6 and he
resigned after king d6 this is the gm
we're speaking about right so this shows
us how
tempting it can be to fall into
illusions and the king gets to c7
but in this position
black and even after king a5 black and
draw but the cleanest draw is to play
king f3 and essentially approach the
white king from behind this is such an
important motif right
very often in your brain you think well
i have to go all the way around to my
pawns but that's not the fastest route
and in this case the fastest route is to
go from behind if white goes king d6 you
go king d4 now of course white can play
c6 and clearly white wins the a pawn but
hopefully you're able to calculate that
after king d4 king b6 king steps up to
d5 and reaches the
promised land just in time it reaches c6
and black is able to make the draw but
this uh doesn't render the actual
breakthrough any less instructive and at
one kasparov of the game without it
white is actually you know struggling to
make a draw uh so the move d5 is white's
only chance and of course if black had
not taken the pawn white pushes d6 and
creates a protected passer uh winning
the game pretty straight forwardly and
that ladies and gentlemen is the end of
the practicum i think 45 minutes it's a
really good amount of time it's a little
faster than i anticipated which is good
and i know i went pretty quickly through
all of these breakthroughs but hopefully
you were able to take all of them down
so we discussed 10 of the most common
types of pawn breakers we examined a
bunch of real game scenarios where a lot
of these breakthroughs are applied and
again are the this is this a
comprehensive examination upon
breakthroughs am i uh catching every
single type of common problem
breakthrough absolutely not but again
i'm just trying to get you to identify
the most common ones and hopefully i was
able to instill in you an appreciation
for the fact that pawn structure
understanding the pawn structure very
keenly right understanding where the
breakthrough could happen can actually
save you a loss position and it can
allow you to convert an end game
advantage king position is also
incredibly important so in addition to
the breakthroughs themselves we also
discussed waiting moves we discussed how
king position can impact breakthroughs
in particular we saw a lot of examples
where your opponent's pawns are actually
preventing the king from stopping the
pass pawn that is created via a
breakthrough and that was a whirlwind
tour of pawn breakthroughs i hope you
enjoyed it and uh as usual i just want
to thank everyone everybody for the
incredibly wholesome feedback on the
first few on game videos it means so
much to me and it motivates me to keep
creating these videos so by all means
sent through your constructive criticism
uh whatever questions you have and i'll
try to get to them but for now i await
you in the next video and thank you so
much for watching
go create some puns via some
breakthroughs goodbye and see you soon
[Music]